For these four examples, we were able to complete the square and turn each
expression into a perfect square by adding a certain amount. The amount that we
added in each case depended upon the b coefficient for the x term. In the first
example, the b term was a 6 and we ended up having to add 9 to make a perfect
square. In the second example, our b was 12 and we ended up adding 36 pieces to
get a perfect square. In this third case, b was negative 4 and we added four
pieces. And in the last case, b was negative 10 and we added 25. So, for any
value of b, how much do you think we need to add in order to complete the
square? In other words, see if you can look and find a pattern between these
two numbers. How do we go from this b to the added amount? Now, you might think
the answer would be b plus 3, but we know that can't be correct. Sure, if we
add 3 here, we get 9. But if I added 3 to 12, I would get 15 and not 36. So,
what expression could we write here that uses the letter b and gives us the
appropriate value? The expression should work for each of the four cases. And
be sure to take some time to think about it. This one's tough. If you get
stuck, look for a hint in the instructor's comment.